who made headlines when she was  photographed topless on the beach in can  I am from Germany yes and we are you  know not as uptight this please don't  wear a top but also you know you have to  understand i go to vote for like an hour  and a half to try and find the most  exclusive piece of beach when it really  nobody and i don't know how they do it  they come with like the scuba thing and  while she couldn't avoid the paps there  was no run-in with her ex seal who  walked the Billboard Music Awards carpet  just 20 minutes earlier it's gonna be a  very eventful evening but I'm really  looking forward to presenting this award  to the great Celine Dion yes she's going  to receive the icon award  you